[Music]
I'm princess Twilight Sparkle and this
is my home
equestrian a land filled with magic
music yeah yeah yeah and most
importantly friendship perfect
[Music]
clowns I ordered how about we start with
you a complete and total surrender
just drop easy as pie we need help to
save Equestria
now
[Music]
it's all i need's I'm the one tempest
one together let's show these little
ponies how it's done magic oh yeah yup
and flowers of ponies
[Music]
no pressure luckily I have amazing
friends were there for me no matter what
[Music]
you have visual on buttercream visual
confirmed go over cleanup
[Applause]
[Music]
on October 6 what you're talking about
saving the world we've got this I wanna
help too can't make you can't we can't
you can't seriously has never been so
sweet my little pony
the movie with an original song
performed by SIA rated PG in theatres
October 6th it is this huge fantastical
journey that you go on with the ponies
whether you see them outside of that
comfort zone silly little ponies yeah
yeah yeah there's much more to these
little ponies than you think your ponies
are crazy we get to meet people beyond
the borders of Equestria I'm so totally
over the cute pony thing when I heard
that my little pony was shopping for
villains I thought here's my little
opportunity let's get the storm started
hey that's good I should treat mark that
there's adventures in the water so we
finally see some sea ponies that she's
just so cute and she has a cute little
people have her in her hair let's show
these little ponies how it's done what I
like about captain Solano is that she
cares for her crew it's really thrilling
to see those hugely talented actors join
us they wrote this character after they
met me I got one word for you sponge
cake
because I love food and I'm also
vertically challenged I played this cool
cat named capper who kind of comes from
the other side of the track he's
handsome handsome man it's a shame that
he see us to be animated
Charming's my game one of the really
exciting things that comes with doing
this movie is now we're moving into an
opportunity to work with live orchestra
in a lot of live musicians takes time
what you talking about audiences can
expect to be taken on a wonderfully
magical exciting ride easy as pie there
are just so many different settings
if you've ever sat through an episode
and just wish you could walk into it
this is that immersive experience it's a
real spectacle and this is a hero's
journey
[Music]
we need to save Equestria on October 6
everyone is joining the pony party easy
as pie ponies
Chris might just drop your ponies are
crazy time plus seaweed wrap let's show
these little ponies how it's done
hi my little pony the movie rated PG in
theaters October 6th
all this power wasted on the parties
there are far greater uses I don't think
those are strong clouds
together but come and here's the deal
ladies I need your magic
do you have the princess she might have
got away a little bit
we need help to save a quest Rhea we're
ready to kick some booty
[Music]
are you male painted pink already to do
this thing
I want to help too
your ponies are crazy now I think
adventure
we got this
you can tell this ends now
[Music]
the magic that's enchanted generations
is finally a movie event October 6 watch
it on the big screen
can't make a weekend again now for the
finishing touch
My Little Pony the movie with an
original song performed by SIA rated PG
in theaters October 6th
[Music]